it's been a parent for quite some time
but Turtles oh grown stuff back here on
the Rich Eisen show one of the stars of
power on Stars season 4 premiered on
back in June every Sunday at 9:00
Eastern time it can check out Jerry
Ferrara we can also see him on shooter
on USA Network we had Omar Epps and the
other day talking about his Cowboys now
Jerry Ferrara from that show as well
back here on the show talking about air
g-man and more good to see you brother
it's good to be here and had a couple of
spirited debates with Omar giant cowboy
talk oh yeah I bet cuz it was funny when
he was here on that was on Monday I
can't even tell any ya Monday Monday
will bleed together um we had Patrick
Peterson on Terrace Yacktman after him
and Patrick was on the phone while we
were wrapping up the segment with Omar
and he's just like yeah I'm like Patrick
Peterson's coming up next he goes we
play them and you know cowboy nation is
going to show up and I put Patrick on
the phone on him on it's real more like
it's it's real with him like he loves
the Cowboys I felt them out we had a
conversation after about two minutes it
wasn't like a cowboy fan or doesn't know
like that dude is savvy and he wants a
ring for Dallas guy he'll in the same
way that you want another one for the
Giants before we move on you want to
soothe his mind at all with a sterling
Shepherd update cuz I know that you're
been concerned about whatever you know
it's just end up being a sprained ankle
that's it badly rolled ankle badly
rolled on because I were when I read
tears I've been I act you got tears in
my eyes when you when you read carted
off in tears it trainer's the whole bit
that usually equals something
particularly awful well you're worse I
immediately went to the place of like oh
maybe it's good we drafted a offensive
receiving tight end then that's where my
mind went to right out of the gate Evan
Engram is one of the this is one and I
don't mean to get you all fired up no
let's do okay and I've said this before
and I'm not just saying it for the
benefit because you're here Jerry Evan
Engram with a healthy sterling Shem bird
and Odell Beckham and now Brandon
Marshall in the role of a number three
receiver wise old Yoda type receiver
that he's never really had to play that
role red zone threat with the Giants
would struggle in absolutely certainly
if you're wonder
about your running game right okay the
defense from last year Landon Collins to
me was the Defensive Player of the Year
last year and I'm expecting that defense
to show up again in the same matter I
think they went I would vote for the
Giants in our poll question today that
they win the NFC certainly if you take
on the Cowboys without Ezekiel Elliott
week one as everyone's expecting in the
Jones Mahal where usually except for
that one moment where Tony Romo stuck it
in Ryan's own with two seconds left
because of the that hurt ball and clock
management than the that the Giants
employed prior III like the Giants to
win the NFC East and I'm not ready to
say it yet fully officially but I like
them to win the NFC period look III
really felt that that was a championship
defense up until Aaron Rodgers threw a
Hail Mary with no time left on the clock
that defense was playing in the playoffs
against the great quarterback really
well now that he'll marry happened and
everything obviously went awry but uh
and we also we lost DRC I'm with you I
try to be realistic but we are certainly
set up to go on a run now you got to
stay healthy you see things that happen
with Shepherd but I am I haven't been I
mean I've been excited in the past but I
am I'm very excited about this giant
because we have defense to go at the
offense it's not just one side of the
ball that's looking good that's true and
now up this kid Evan Engram I I'm really
high on him I'm really his athletic
skill set and I'm told that his blocking
skills is also something that don't
worry about is it yeah not that's what
I'm hearing he's blowing defensive ends
away and and these do one of the back
step up which will be huge for us if one
of these running backs if part Perkins
or even if an get Vereen healthy for
more than a few games if someone steps
up I'm surprised didn't go after
LeGarrette Blount I thought that was
going to happen that would have any
great fit perfect in there but now he's
with the Eagles I know if they would
have maybe met the Patriots in the Super
Bowl that would be a great little
storyline for us to talk about the
Eagles still leading our poll question
of who's winning the NFC East let's take
a look the Eagles are 26% the Cowboys
are twenty five and a half percent the
Giants are twenty four and a half
and and the Redskins are 23 and a half
are you only running this poll in
Philadelphia I'm surprised too
all right when type three what's
happening all Sean Jeffrey LeGarrette
Blount and that mix they already you
know I'd you're DiMasi sitting there
Ryan Matthews coming back right I'm not
missing anything on that front
the Eagles defense I still need to see
that to believe that I like here's how
I'm going you tell me if how many if I'm
guys uh cuz you know gameday morning
season previews coming up in about three
weeks yes and we're here yeah they were
here we're uh I'm thinking of another
one last Brady Eli go at it in Minnesota
another Wow another dome Stadium
one last Brady Eli showdown for Tom to
go for six one for the other thumb and
he finally play the a la Dragon or Eli
that this is a delicious a storyline is
out there or the Kryptonite one more
time gets his third and he seals his
Hall of Fame credentials undoubtedly now
I know the cowboys and everyone else in
that division have an issue with it air
hackers Seahawks Cardinals someone from
the NFC South is going to be better than
we think is that happens every year oh
yeah I'm thinking about I mean I can't
get your kinky joke oh no three and OH
against Tom Brady I mean that that that
does something for your legacy I think
that's probably going to be the most
unique legacy you could have really yeah
about it I'm not saying like that it
makes him the greatest quarterback ever
I'm just saying you go three and OH
argue against arguably the greatest
quarterback ever he is I think that
we've already we that's how we started
our show even though we weren't
expecting right I mean that definitely
adds to a unique legacy that I don't
think you could really find with any
other player where he built his legacy
on beating the one guy who's the best
who concerns you though in the NFC more
than anybody I mean look I always going
into Philadelphia concerns me I can't
feel like the Giants having one in
Philadelphia in a long time
um I I get a little nerve I just get the
Packer scare me but Aaron Roger scares
me the most
he scares me more because I said like I
I meant what I said that defense the
giant defense in the first half was
playing amazing the package could not
move the ball Oh dill and I feel out
ally that have to Odell did drop that
passed but the Packers still had Ally
and then the second half was just a
bloodbath Aaron Rodgers scares me the
most because when he gets read hard
nothing you could do you're helpless
exactly but you have to win that
division
I think the Giants need to win that
division get a home game maybe even a
bye week and that were nice and well I
know that would be nice but I think
that's what they need to have where as
Aaron Rodgers is we you know can go on
some run on the road and he's done that
before etc etc even though Eli has come
from the wild-card spot beat and foggy
me he ended Favre's Packers career such
a great road warrior tiny in confluence
bases still by the way I think we talked
about that last I think is one of the
best subplots in a great game that
you're watching like is Tom Coughlin
going to lose part of his face is
beautiful rose by by the way we'll take
a break and come back and talk talk some
hoops and some baseball with you Jerry
Ferrara okay we had Coughlin on the show
what was that about a month ago
ah yes front office of Nate on the Japs
they said he is calling in at 10:45 in
the morning Pacific time we took our
breaks to make sure we were back by
10:40 guess what rang it for 10:40
Coughlin time
Copland time he's calling at 10:45 seen
better be ready at 10:00 foyers exactly
we did love it we're back in 60 seconds
with Jerry Ferrara I am going to wean
Jerry Ferrara off the New York Knicks
that's next year in the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Jerry Ferrara
hanging out with us here in the show
studio so uh apparently a little bit of
sigh of relief for you at sterling
Shepherd in the Giants and the wide
receiver we'll see what happens
the the Los Angeles chargers for years
is the San Diego Chargers and Phillip
Rivers having trouble being protecting
because that offensive line would have
so much injury on it to protect him Tina
and Alan's gone down two of the last
three years
Oh so what are the charges do first
round they go Mike Williams wide
receiver out of Clemson and then they go
forest lamp a an offensive lineman out
of Western Kentucky one of the top of
linemen on mike Mayock straf boards Mike
Williams has yet to show up in training
camp on a practice field because of a
back injury and forest lamp was just
carted off about ten minutes ago Oh with
an apparent right leg injury I mean are
the charger it doesn't matter where they
are right now snake bit snake that Bo
says you remember last year didn't play
the first couple games because he held
out so long Wow so another injury to
keep an eye on with Forest lamp carted
off in Costa Mesa where the Chargers are
holding their first practices as the Los
Angeles chargers LaDainian Tomlinson is
on tomorrow's edition to the Richardson
shows he goes into the Pro Football Hall
of Fame in Canton Ohio so you and the
Knicks now out of all the teams Yankees
Knicks Giants if I had to give you a
choice of one team that had to win it
all
who would that be not even a question
the Knicks because it's the only it's
the only look I've been very spoiled I
it's the only franchise loyalty I have
that has not given me a championship in
my lifetime so why are you so loyal to
the Knicks because I grew up I grew you
you weren't looking ok stat now right ok
my guy growing up Bernard King sure
right yeah ok before that we're talking
about like the Rory Sparrow Bill
Cartwright Marvin Webster Knicks yeah I
think I'm a little bit older
right I remember that was wasn't that
part of the Oakley trades notable oh
this is pre Bernard King that's how I go
be I go beyond you even suffering longer
than correctly correct and I remember I
was driving with my parents and my
brother to our aunt and uncle's house in
New Jersey in the back of the Pontiac
blue safari station wagon we heard on on
wi NS radio the news flash that the
Knicks had gotten Patrick Ewing they won
the lottery I remember where I remember
my flashbulb memory I remember where I
was when Dave the butcher won the
lottery for the Knicks
you know I could really I could recall
the first basketball game that I watched
as a kid I actually knew everything that
was going on and it was a Knicks bowled
game I think it was on Martin Luther
King Day when Trent Tucker at the
three-point I remember that game does
the first one does the first bad thing
my watch where I knew everything they
changed the rules on how much time you
can be able to point or became right
they need you needed at least point
three or point more to get a shot off
because Trent Tucker did not get that no
long I got a long history with this team
I can't a lot hi I'm done Jerry why you
can't be done why because that's what
being a sports fan is all about the
suffrage in it when they get to the
point thirty years from now we're
sitting here and they have a title maybe
take 30 years it'll be worth it his
Dolan still dealer probably yeah like
the eyelid Jerry they dragged Charles
Oakley no out of MSG
I know I didn't read you know ass out of
there that her and Dolan let him sit in
jail for a night that that hurt are you
kidding me that hurt I mean to me that
that tore it up and then the number of
times that we have seen coaches being
brought in general managers being
brought in even he touched Phil and Phil
died I'm like digging into your chair
I'm serious re-examine my closet but
then then there's a purple unicorn like
like you know he that right that
porzingis comes along and it renews your
hope and then they drag oakley out of
there to me that was it for me that was
it for me and he done especially since
he says Dolan says Phil can steak Eve
no his 80 in 166 record should bounce
him regardless he can stay
uh let's labs and pick the groceries
even though we here as he's falling
asleep during some during some practices
nodding right tell me where I'm wrong on
this all right and then let's let him
draft
threatened porzingis ruin relationships
with our best commodity and our best
hold you have for a system that nobody
wants to run and then fire who and then
and then and let Carmelo dangle I mean
let's let's give him let's give him a no
trade clause and then and then drag his
name through the mud in in the media and
all all a while this guy have you seen
JD in the street chance play have you
Gabby are you the Hierophant yes well I
have not been live when we bother Sam
you've taken in on tonight I mean I've
definitely download on the YouTube I'm
going to see what it's all about maybe
even had like I really did enjoy that
there was a concert on draft night that
he had to attend that was that was
really I had some fun on Twitter with
that one um I'm all for delegating to
people who are the things that they're
supposed to be doing but not when you're
thinking of firing them and they're
threatening to trade your best commodity
that's where you need to get the hands
on ten and two I hate the car keys away
from your kid I only have one thing that
would make me be out lie under stand why
you're on the case you just laid out
I really cannot refute anything you just
said and encourage you to still stay a
fan I get it the only thing I will say
is once you're out it's really hard to
come back in ten years if they're good
we will remember that you're out rich
and that's fine you could and you might
say I'm still out that that was enough
for me to be out the only thing that
would really were they would make me go
if they traded poor thing it's like that
was the scariest I hate what they did to
mellow and I actually I want Mel to get
traded because I want him to go
somewhere it's like it's like an ex that
you really want to go on and like meet
someone great like go I want you to have
a great life like I want him to go be
successful yes I'm still in I will
always be in if they traded porzingis
and those rumors are what hurt me
whether they were true or not
so what hurt me the most if they did
that then I would be out you'd be out
yes like to the point where 10 years
from now I'm still out still out
I have you're selling me out but right
now you're still in I'm in yes so I'm
going to Jerry Ferrara I'm trying to let
this studio this show be the equivalent
of the white van that I've thrown you in
the back of to deprogram you and send
you back to your family a better person
and you're not you're still in love with
your captor it's essentially what you're
saying the the feelings that those 90s
Nicks gave me and this is a Tina did not
even win a championship and broke my
heart in 94 against the Rockets but
those feelings of watching those NBA on
NBC games and all it just there was
nothing like it for me Marv did those
game I remember Dolan soon him I know I
know I know I fell in love with the
Knicks and this type of job throw Marv
Dolan sent him out to I'm telling you
those days are gone just do what I do
while you trade half your team for Kyrie
Irving that's what I mean I have a good
team in law now I'm a married man who's
your team in law she's from Cleveland so
I have a team in law out of the Cavs
although they they have some rough going
on the Clippers here Lonzo
I can't I can't like for all my friends
growing up that jump ship the minute the
nets move to Brooklyn like to me that's
just that's just like the biggest sports
in you can commit I can't do it I can't
do I don't I don't flip-flop I've
managed to still enjoy basketball
without having a hat in the ring I still
love watching the game Larry Jerry yeah
so let me just take one last one look at
you look at your if we showed this Jerry
Ferrara to the Jerry Ferrara what 15 20
years ago okay oh okay
you'd be like yes that's the jet that's
Jerry Ferrara okay why do you need to
now be still a Knick fan from that Jerry
Ferrara when you have been toyed with
messed with absolutely abandoned
abandoned
you can't look at me I'm staring even
looking at you okay look fine let's
revisit this let's revisit this next
time you come in and see just put a pin
in this think about this and every time
Dolan does something stupid which is
let's set our watch or next time the
Knicks disappoint think of me think of
this conversation I can't I can't do it
rich I can't I can't leave them I can't
what I can't it's what being to me it's
it's what supports fandom is all about
you have to get through this highs in
the love and short for fnatic got to
deal with the pain to enjoy the success
you know I'm can Belle fanatic without
fan um
power shooter what else you got going on
right now man it's all crushing you're
doing a great job yeah I everything I
actually want to slow down as a to UM to
lazy's or too much I want to take
sometimes to know um yeah I mean I'm
getting ready to leave to go back to New
York for a job I can't really talk too
much about now but probably okay in a
year from now uh what life is good I
have to say I'm very very lucky and if
the Knicks can just turn around I got no
language okay how is in you and your now
I mean that that ring on your finger
yeah old like a month that's it yes I
finally got a ring it's not as you know
we do this that's the Mick Fanning Joe a
bad I got a ring and finally got that
Riggs I got a ring I do any any any mean
as you said oh how she's from Ohio yeah
she like I said we been Lions my good
buddy kind of created this team in law
thing so we have such a good trade-off
where like she gets the Giants over the
browns I get the Cavs over the Knicks so
like we have a good and the Indians and
Yankees are on good Pat so we have a
good sports relationship my team's in
law or all New England why I've always
been single rich my team win okay their
love is a battlefield I have seeded
ground up on the Patriots because I
cannot you know I grew up a jet fan oh
yeah I can't Child Services would come
take me away if during the Brady
Belichick era my children grew up and
didn't side with their mom I mean I
talked about getting you off the jet we
could I could flip this right back on
you about
how oft that am i right off am I've been
on but I mean I'm still I'm still in you
some what they're happy yeah because the
Jets Woody Johnson didn't drag Joe
Namath whole [ __ ] out of the stadium
breathe relax
thank you you could tell when I get yeah
I love a guy or not rich I love and
whiskey I fired up my favorite rich cut
me off in traffic yes good to see a man
um you've got power shooter on Stars and
USA Network respectively and even more
importantly beautiful life at home so
congratulations on all that Jerry come
back when you're when you're free
anytime we'll talk fantasy will do also
yeah this stuff yes ok Jerry Ferrara
still in the mix a stranglehold for
whatever is reasoning I guess um he's
the beauty and the Knicks of the Beast
he's still stuck in the library the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slow-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about